good afternoon ketanji brown jackson
would be the first black woman to serve
on the u.s supreme court if confirmed
the daughter of school teachers who
themselves had attended segregated
schools
jackson was once advised by a high
school counselor that harvard university
was out of reach it wasn't she graduated
with top honors and stay to study law
the beginning of a brilliant legal
career
i can only hope that my life and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded
will inspire future generations of
americans i think having
judge jackson as justice jackson will
really open up to
so many more people in the united states
and around the world to the possibility
that there aren't limitations and that
if there are little girls all around the
country who say one day i'd like to be
on the highest court of the land they
can look at justice jackson and know
that that is an entirely probable path
for them
jackson is currently serving on the
federal court of appeals for the d.c
circuit she's been there for only a few
months nominated by biden and confirmed
by the u.s senate in june in a vote that
included yeses from three republicans
the white house is hoping for a repeat
performance her opinions are always
carefully reasoned
tethered to precedent and demonstrate
reflect respect for how the law impacts
everyday people jackson has a record as
a liberal jurist in 2019 as a district
court judge she blocked president
trump's attempts to shield a former
white house aide from testifying before
congress famously writing presidents are
not kings
she's also worked as a federal public
defender once assigned to represent an
afghan guantanamo bay detainee among
other people accused of crimes but
unable to pay for their own defense
i think that
that perspective will allow her to have
an insight into
the human element of of cases which none
of the other justices will obviously
share because none of them have this
this experience president biden is
looking for a swift confirmation in the
evenly divided senate where a simple
majority will be needed and likely
delivered that's despite criticism from
some prominent republicans like senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell who
claims jackson is the favored choice of
far left dark money groups
if confirmed jackson would replace
another liberal justice stephen breyer
when he retires this summer that would
leave the supreme court's 6-3 majority
unchanged but at age 51 jackson has the
potential to serve for decades on the
high court and adding a historic win to
biden's legacy thank you all heidi joe
castro al jazeera washington